-You know I love podcasts.
-Oh, you love them.
-I do.
-You love them.
-I love podcasts. I like Mike
Birbiglia's "Working It Out."
Listen to that.
I love "The Daily."
-Yep.
-I love any of the --
-You love that Raz -- Guy Raz's.
-I do, "How I Built --"
Yeah, they're a great way
to pass the time
on your way to work,
going for a walk,
whatever you're doing.
But the other day,
I was scrolling through
my podcast app.
-Mm-hmm.
-I have an app
that's just all podcasts.
Do you have an app?
-Yeah, it's called "Podcast."
[ Laughter ]
But you're scrolling through --
-I was scrolling through my app.
-While you were taking a walk.
-I was taking a walk.
And I'm scrolling.
-Sure.
-You know, multitasking.
-Yeah, you do that all the time.
-But I noticed there's
a lot of obscure podcasts
that I've never even
heard of before.
-Really?
-Yeah.
So I thought we could maybe
check out a few of them tonight.
It's time for
"Tonight Show Podcasts."
Here we go.
-♪ "Tonight Show Podcasts" ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, this first --
-Oh, you're going
to listen to them?
-What's that?
I can't hear you when --
-You're going to listen to
the podcasts. Okay, never mind.
-Our first podcast is --
Oh, it's in here.
-Oh, there you go.
-My first podcast is called
"Vin Diesel Lists
All the Bands at Woodstock."
-Really?
-That's a podcast.
Yeah, it's where Vin Diesel --
-Sure.
-Well, he lists all the bands
that were at Woodstock.
-At Woodstock.
[ Laughter ]
-Let's check it out.
Listen to this.
-Alright. I didn't know
he was a giant music fan.
-That's the whole podcast?
-Yeah.
That's the whole thing. Yeah.
This next one is a podcast
adaptation of "Hot Ones."
I love "Hot Ones."
You know, Sean Evans?
He eats spicy chicken wings
with celebrities.
-Right.
-But I'm not sure
how it's going to translate,
since it's so visual.
-Right.
-But it's really big.
I mean, it's #4
on the podcast chart.
-Wow. On your podcast chart.
-Yeah, on my -- Yeah.
On my app.
-Yeah, on your app.
-Yep.
-Jimmy's Podcast App.
-No, I have nothing to do
with the app.
I'm not selling my app.
-But if you were...
-Yeah, but I'm not. So, anyway,
I'm just saying, this is --
I don't know
if it's going to translate.
But, anyways, it's #4.
-#4.
-Yeah, on the app.
-Let's hear it.
-Let's take a listen.
-[ High-pitched screaming,
vocalizing ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was Mariah Carey.
-Got to avoid the hot ones.
By the end, they get hotter.
-That's hot.
-This one here is called --
-That #2 or #4? Was it #4?
-It'll always be #2 in my book.
[ Laughter ]
Appreciate it.
I have to take these off
'cause they are noise canceling,
so I can't hear you.
-What's that?
-You're wearing them?
-I'm wearing them,
but they're in-ear.
-You can't hear me, either?
Oh, in-ear.
-Hold on. They're very tiny.
-That's the new Apple one?
[ Pops lips ]
-There we go. What'd you say?
-Oh, this one here,
this is an interesting one here.
This one's called
"Accent Masterclass."
-"Accent Masterclass."
-Yeah, each week, it helps
listeners master a new accent.
-Oh, great.
-Let's check it out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It helps you master the accent.
-That's great! Yeah.
-Squeeze Cheese.
Tommy.
-This last podcast is called --
-Oh, you're going to plug it in?
Oh, wow, it's wireless.
Is that a big antenna?
It's like wireless?
-That's what makes it --
It's Bluetooth.
-Oh. You have a blue tooth?
-It's -- No, this --
The wire makes it --
-Oh, makes it Bluetooth.
-I can hear it anywhere.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like a Tamagotchi
or whatever, yeah.
-Yeah, it's like -- Yeah. Right
now, I can hear any podcast.
-So, it's like a radar?
-You hook this up to the app...
-Right.
-...you can get
any podcast you want.
-Wow. And it downloads --
-This last podcast --
This last podcast --
-Is that the last podcast?
-I'm gonna scroll down.
-Oh, there you go. Scroll down.
Scroll down. Scroll down.
Wow. 3,285.
Wow! That's the last one?
-Mm-hmm. This last one here,
this is obscure.
This one's called --
It's called "Knock Knock
with Vladimir Putin."
-Really?
-It's a podcast where Putin
tells knock knock jokes
to make himself seem like
a friendlier person,
more people can relate to him.
I don't know.
Let's take a listen.
-Yeah, seriously. That's all --
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's all we have
for "Tonight Show Podcasts."